कि नमस्कार जर्मनी के हिंदी में कि ने इस
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम एक
इंटर्नशिप सीखने वाले हैं जो प्लस
इन्फ्लेटेड यह इंपोर्टेंट इसलिए है कि
इससे आप थोड़े कंपलेक्स सेंटेंसेस बना
सकते हो अभी अनफॉर्चूनेटली यह थोड़ी सी
अपनी यह थोड़ी सी नहीं है पर अपने को एक
और फायदा है हमारे लिए कि इट्स वेरी
सिमिलर टो इंग्लिश तो सिर्फ इस कंसेप्ट के
लिए हम क्या करने वाले हैं कि हम उसका जो
इंग्लिश के साथ सिमिलैरिटी है उसका यूज
करके करने वाले हैं तो लेट्स सी क्यों
इंग्लिश में कहते हो तो पहले अगर आपने
इंग्लिश में वह निकली समझ गया ना तो जर्मन
में करना बहुत ही इजी है तो इंग्लिश में
क्या होता है जो प्रेजेंटेड टो हिस टू
इंग्लिश में टुक प्लेस इन थे है जो तो यह
सेंटेंस तीन देखो तो आपको क्लिक एकदम
क्लियर हो जाएगा कि कितना इंच है क्योंकि
आर्मी डे टुडे लाइफ में इंग्लिश में यूज
करते हैं देखो आईटी ट्राइड टो लर्न जर्मन
हाय ट्राइड टो लर्न जर्मन
हु इज इंपोर्टेंट टू लर्न जर्मन इड
इंपॉर्टेंट टू लर्न जर्मन या फिर नो टाइम
टो लव आईएस नो टाइम टो लर्न जर्मन देखोगे
ऐसे सेंटेंस में यूज करते हो तो पहले
पढ़ने को पति का नाम था टू लर्न जर्मन
इसमें इस सेंटेंस सेंटेंस जो दूसरा पार्ट
है उसमें घ्र में के लिए सब्जेक्ट है में
सब कुछ नहीं है
यो यो हनी सिंह के साथ सब्जी का फर्स्ट
पार्ट और जो वर्ड है वह इंफिनिटिव में
रखें खुद को तीनों में भी क्या है कि टू
लर्न जर्मन सिमिलरली बिहेव करता है कि नो
सब्जेक्ट और टू व्हीलर टू व्हीलर अपने
इंफिनिटिव में रख लिया है सबको और पहले
पहला पाठ देखो तीनों सेंटेंस का पहले
सेंटेंस में क्या है देखो आईटी ट्राइड टो
लर्न जर्मन कुंवर यूज किया है और ट्राइड
टो एक्सप्लेन टो लर्न जर्मन आई हॉप टू
लर्न जर्मन कर सकते हुए आगे कुछ वक्त से
अब यह कर सकते हो आई टू लर्न जर्मन नहीं
चलेगा फिर कुछ स्पेसिफिक वर्ष इंग्लिश में
जो वह यूज करते हैं करेक्ट पिओगे पहला भाग
दूसरा टेस्ट किया था देखो इंडीज
इंपॉर्टेंट टू लर्न जर्मन एडिट यूज किया
अपने आप ऐसे भी बोल सकते हो इट इज इट टू
लर्न जर्मन इट्स गुड टू लर्न जर्मन इट इज
ऑलवेज एक्टिव इस अनदर और थर्ड जॉब सबसे कम
यूज करते हैं आई एम नो टाइम टो लर्न जर्मन
यह सही नहीं है जब उसने को लेकर आया हूं
नो इंटेंशन टो लर्न जब यह तीन बेसिक
टाइप्स जिससे हम यह टू प्लस इंफिनिटिव
वाले सेंटेंस बनाते हैं जर्मन में भी
एक्जेक्टली सेम करने अगर आपको यहां तक समझ
में आया तो जरूर एकदम सिंपल है जब मैंने
सिर्फ डिफरेंस क्या है कि यह निबंध आज बन
जाते हैं निबंधमोबाइल जैसे तो वह जाएगा
एंड में बाकी खोज-परख है ठीक है तो यह 13
और टाइप्स हम एक के बाद एक के बाद जर्मन
में देखते हैं पहला टाइप क्या है विद
स्पेसिफिक वर विद स्पेसिफिक वर आईएस
ट्राइड टो लर्न जर्मन का ट्राइड टो लर्न
जर्मन क्या होगा प्राइस फरूख खन इस पेरू
खरीदवाए जूलर न सिर्फ जूलर में NET में
गया बाकी कोई
कि इस वर्ष जोकर दौरान दुल्हन अंग सपोर्ट
करो न चल रहा है इसलिए हमको क्रिकेट खेलने
को नहीं मिल रहे तो हम वह पिन की हुई वह
टू प्ले करें तो क्या होगा ग्य ह अपन हम
है इसलिए यह फंदा क्रिकेट जूस पीने है
एकदम सिंपलेस्ट आपके जैसे इंग्लिश में
वर्ड थे वैसे ही जर्मन में कुछ फर्ज है वह
वर्ग के साथ है यूज कर सकते हो वैसे कुछ
वर्ष की लिस्ट मैंने यहां पर दिए हैं कि
जगदीश्वर पोस्टर आर्ट एंड प्लैनेट्स
एक्स्ट्रा देखोगे इन थे और प्योर रन
एक्स्ट्रा डेविड इंजन लगा है वहीं लिस्ट
आप देख ही सकते हैं इन जनरल जो वर्ड्स आप
इंग्लिश में यूज कर सकते हो उसी वर्ष के
साथ आप जर्मन में भी यूज कर सकते हैं
बेसिक आइडिया क्या है एक ही याद रखो इस पर
जो का दायित्व जो लेमन एकदम सिंपल है
दूसरा जो पार्ट है तो उससे भी सिंपल है कि
बाइक एडजेक्टिव लौंग और उसके आगे यह लगाओ
कि
इंपॉर्टेंट टू लर्न जर्मन एसिड योग्य
किड्स टो लर्न जर्मन एसिड फतवे जूलर गुड
टो लर्न सिंपल है
पीछे एक और एग्जांपल लेते हैं फिर
इंपोर्टेंट टू प्ले क्रिकेट एसएस बिष्ट
क्रिकेट जोश पीले रंग वेरी सिंपल कि जस्ट
पार्ट थर्ड पार्टी जैम बहुत कम बार यूज
करते हैं वह है वहां वन या फिर मक्खन का
उपयोग हाफ वनप्लस अननोन कि आई एम नोट टाइम
अगर आपको बोलना है इस हां पक्का इंतजाम
पेट दवाई जूलर मंदिर बस टाइम नहीं है
जर्मन सीखने के लिए इस हबक हिना साइड
दौरान जूलर इन थे वैसे आप बना सकते हो कि
अच्छा और थोड़े से हैं जो मैंने आपको दिए
डाइट हवन की तरह ही अब जिस 58 लास्ट हवन
मतलब मेरी इच्छा नहीं है मेरी कोई इच्छा
नहीं है उससे मिलने के घर को अपने हिसाब
से काटना डिस्टर्ब फिर इस बकायेदार लुक्स
अप कर सकते हो या फिर पास मंदिर होता है
इट्स गुड लक स्मार्ट 52 जूलर ऐसे भी आप कर
सकते हो रहेगा आगे इनको यह थोड़े से
कंस्ट्रक्ट्स हैं जिनके साथ आप यूज कर
सकते हो
यह बहुत कम बार होगा तो वह और हमने क्या
देखा बहुत सिंपल है कि जूस प्लस इंफिनिटी
होते हुए के दो प्रमुख पहले पार्ट में
क्या-क्या हो सकता है कुछ वर्ग है जिसे
इंग्लिश में होती है वैसी फैसु खन की तरह
दूसरा क्या है अमरुद एक्टिव के साथ बोल
सकते हैं हिस्ट्रीशीटर यह कहना और तीसरा
कुछ कंस्ट्रक्ट होते हैं यह पक्का इनसाइड
यह बकायन लास्ट और जो दूसरा पार्ट है वह
नॉर्मल है इंग्लिश की तरह है यह सेंटेंस
नॉर्मली बन्ना सिर्फ झूठ के साथ बनेगा वह
झूठ प्लस में इंफिनिटिव वह एंड में जाएगा
याद रखो इस पेड़ उखड़ गए जो लेयर न एकदम
सिंपल है बट अभी जस्ट कंप्लीट द कंसेप्ट
जब प्रेम व लूंगी अगर आफ खन होगा या
अनुरूपण होगा तो स्वप्न दोष नहीं होगा और
प्रखंड के बीच में झगड़ा और डुबोकर
अनुरूपण के बीच में जरूर जानता अंजु फॉर
एग्जांपल
ए ब्रॉड टाइम नहीं है किरदार को फोन करने
को आयाम नो टाइम टो कॉल केंद्र
कि इस हां पक्का इनसाइड केदार अनुरूपण
सिंपल एंड स्टमक एसिड किरदार अनुरूपण
इंपॉर्टेंट 19 स्टिच लुट-लुट थ्रू व कर्ण
के नाते यूज करोगे उसमें कितनी बार फिर
ठीक है इसलिए अपने पर अभी गाड़ी
इंपोर्टेंट है मैं बोलता हूं सिर्फ तीन
सेंटेंस अगर आप यह याद रखोगे ना तो एक
सिंपल न सब्सक्राइब करें इससे करके देख
सकते हो यह बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है कि कैसे
अनफॉर्चूनेटली हमने इंग्लिश में यह बहुत
ही इंपोर्टेंट डू समथिंग टो दो समथिंग आप
किसी
भावनगर सोचूंगी तो किस सोच कैंटर सेम रहती
है तो कि दिमाग में इस सेंटेंस आएंगे मैं
बहुत बार देखता हूं मेरे एवं चूर्ण यह
करने की कोशिश करते हैं तो नाउ यह पॉइंट
टू द है तो प्राइवेट इंग्लिश सेंटेंसेस
बेस रूल जो अपने सिखाता हूं याद रखना और
कंसेप्ट बहुत सिंपल है मुझे आशा है कि
आपको यह कनेक्ट समझ में आई होगी हम मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में डालने वाले